how much water does it take to actually
pop one of these Foley Bloons I don't
know let's see this experiment is
inspired by a comment someone left me
about how a nurse was supposed to be
flushing the FY catheter but instead was
adding water into the balloon insulation
Port so I want to see how much this
thing can actually hold Safety First
here I have a Foley it is a 5cc balloon
so I'm going to start out injecting 10
of water in it so this should be easy
cheesy okay so there's 10 go another 10
equaling 20 little hard to push got to
push a little bit okay
another 10 equal
30 okay that's pretty big 40 actually I
can push it pretty well really blowing
up there this is going to make 50 I
don't think that would feel too good
setting in your
bladder oh there we
go okay so 5 CC balloon 50 is what
popped it if you ever have orders to
flush the folley make sure you're using
the right Port because you don't want to
bust this thing in sold your patient's
bladder